Hallo Stefan.
Grüß dich Wolfgang.
Wir müssen noch ankündigen, was wir im nächsten Salon lesen werden und normalerweise
suchen wir uns Bücher aus,
die gerade frisch erschienen sind und wir haben viel gestöbert in den aktuellen
Verlagsprospekten, haben aber nicht so richtig was gefunden.
Also im Februar haben wir wieder und März aktuelles gefunden,
was uns sehr interessiert.
Und dann fiel mir ein, ich habe da doch von einem Hörer ein Buch geschickt bekommen
vor einer Weile von dem Hörer Till und er sagte hier, Rutger Bregmann,
im Grunde gut, das würde dich sehr interessieren.
Und dann fiel mir ein, ja, das ist ja auch in unserer Podcast-Zeit erschienen
in den 29ern, aber wir haben es nie besprochen.
Inzwischen gibt es das auch als Taschenbuch und wir dachten,
wir könnten uns diesem Buch mal annehmen.
Es ist nämlich ein Mega-Welt-Bestseller geworden und es hat ja die These,
dass der Mensch im Grunde gut ist und dass man von dieser Prämisse ausgehend
sehr viel mehr im Hinblick auf Klimawandel, im Hinblick auf soziale Veränderungen machen könnte.
Als man gemeinhin annimmt.
Und hier steht auch schon auf dem Klappentext, dass der Mensch grundsätzlich böse sei,
ist ein Grundpfeiler westlichen Denkens und das Buch ist ja auch untertitelt
mit eine neue Geschichte der Menschheit und so reiht sich dieses Buch vielleicht
ganz gut ein in unsere vielen Bücher, die wir besprochen haben,
die nochmal so den ganz großen Wurf machen wollen,
beispielsweise ja auch David Graeber,
der uns eine neue Geschichte der Menschheit dort erzählt hat.
Ja, das Publikationsdatum ist ja ganz interessant, bei Amazon steht hier 10. März 2020.
Da stürzte also die Welt gerade ins Chaos. Wir können also, während wir immer
noch keine gute Corona-Aufarbeitung haben,
dieses grundlegende Buch über die Menschheit mal auch unter dem Gesichtspunkt,
woran der Autor nicht dachte, was aber auch Realität ist, hält es denn stand?
Lesen und ich sehe hier in der Liste anderer Publikationen vom selben Autor.
Utopien für Realisten und sowas.
Es
Sollte also nicht durch einen Corona-Wind umzuhauen sein, was da drin steht
in seinen Prinzipien und Paradigmen.
Da können wir gespannt sein.
So hoffen wir doch. Er hat sich ja auch dann in Davos beim Weltwirtschaftsforum
immer wieder mit den Mächtigen angelegt, gesagt, nein, ihr müsst jetzt mal zahlen,
ihr müsst besteuert werden und da gibt es jetzt auch keine Ausreden mehr.
Ich bin sehr gespannt, ob es auch so ein radikales Buch ist.
Yuval Noah Harari lobt es. Er sagt, im Grunde gut hat mich dazu bewegt,
die Menschheit aus einer neuen Perspektive zu betrachten.
Ich kann es nur empfehlen. Also wir schließen uns dieser Empfehlung noch nicht an.
Das wird sich zeigen, aber ich glaube, es ist ein Buch, über das wir sehr gut diskutieren können.
Und wir hoffen, weil es zwar von einem Historiker ist, aber doch eine sehr philosophische
Grundlage hat, wir hoffen, dass es sich einmal fundamental unterscheidet von
all den Akzelerationisten und Longtermism Leuten und wen wir da so alles hatten.
Auch wenn Bregmann da glaube ich auch gewisse Beziehungen zumindest zu dem Longtermism pflegt.
Wir werden da aber schauen, was das Buch hergibt und haben da jedenfalls eine
ganz gute Diskussionsgrundlage für den neuen Salon. Es.
Ist auf jeden Fall eine Menge Text, du hast es ja da in der Hand,
ich werde es digital lesen, da fehlt mir immer der Überblick, aber es ist 400 Seiten.
Es geht.
400, okay, gute Materialsammlung. Ich werde ergänzen und zwar ganz aktuell,
ich weiß auch noch nicht genau, was sich dahinter verbirgt, aber übermorgen
kommt von Alexander Thiele, dem schon häufig von uns erwähnten Verfassungsrechtsprofessoren,
defekte Visionen, eine Intervention zur Zukunft der Europäischen Union.
Wir erleben gerade auf der Straße, wir werden das ja wahrscheinlich nicht allzu
ausführlich, es wurde schon viel darüber gesagt und wir können diesmal mehr
so anschließen an unsere eigenen bisherigen Gespräche.
Wir erleben gerade auf der Straße wie eine schuldenbremsenangeleitete Kürzungsdiskussion.
Politische Paradigmen, die 2020 in der Europäischen Union festgezurrt wurden,
nämlich in der gemeinsamen Agrarpolitik, der GAP, über die wir uns damals lustig
machten, weil sie im Deutschen Bundestag verabschiedet wird,
wo nur der Agrarausschuss nochmal inhaltlich reinschaut, wo aber nicht die Agrarlobby
davor sitzt, sondern mittendrin.
Also wo einfach die Agrarlobby selbst das Mandat trägt.
Und das sieht man jetzt gerade auf der Straße, ohne dass das im großen Bogen diskutiert wird.
Wo diese Gesetze herkommen, wo die Drangsalierungen der Bauern herkommen,
was ist europäische Agrarpolitik, was soll denn das sein?
Von daher ist es immer interessant, ein Update zur Europäischen Union zu bekommen,
insbesondere wenn sie von jemandem so aufgeklärten wie Alexander Thiele,
der ja jüngst auch wieder im Bundestag
als Sachverständiger zum Schuldenbremsenurteil und so weiter aussagte.
Ja und zu dem neuen Sanktionspaket, das man da haben möchte gegen Bürgergeldempfänger,
wo er auch sagte, na so einfach ist das nicht, wie die sich das vorstellen.
Karlsruhe sieht das anders.
All diese Sachen, fangen wir von ihm nochmal in Ruhe, 150 Seiten zu den defekten
Visionen, auch sehr schöner Titel, also da verspreche ich uns viel von,
das wird sozusagen aktuelle Zweigleisigkeit,
die große Menschheitsfrage und dann die ganz aktuelle,
wie kriegen wir es denn auf die Straße?
Ja, und auch die Frage, stimmt das wirklich, dass die Leute im Grunde gut sind?
Also wir nehmen hier um 16 Uhr an einem Montag auf, vor einer Stunde oder zwei
ist Christian Lindner aufgetreten vor den Bauern in Berlin und beschimpft die
Ampelregierung, zu der er offenbar in diesem Augenblick dann nicht gehört.
Gehört und ist dort mit Worten unterwegs und mit einer Demagogie,
anders kann man es nicht nennen, dass man doch seine Zweifel an so einer Prämisse bekommt,
wie sie Rutger Bregmann hier uns anbietet.
Aber vielleicht ist es ja alles ganz anders, vielleicht können wir auch nach
der Lektüre Christian Lindner bessern, wir schauen, was wir damit machen,
also das ist die gemeinsame Lektüre.
Vorsätze zum neuen Jahr einfach.
Christian Lindner besser machen, gar nicht selbst besser werden,
sondern Christian Lindner besser machen.
Wir schauen mal den Salon, den gibt es über Patreon,
über Apple, aber wir präferieren Steady, man kann auf die Steady Seite gehen,
am besten geht man auf neue 20er, geht dort auf den Salon Button und wird dann direkt dahin geleitet.
Wer uns über Spotify hört und auch weiterhin dort hören will und den Salon auch
dort hören will, kann auch dann über Spotify auf den Button klicken und kommt dann zum Salon.
Es sollte also alles kein Problem sein und dann hören wir uns aber erst einmal
Ende des Monats zur regulären Folge und da schauen wir mal, was dann noch so los ist auf den Straßen.
Yes, das werden wir tun. Bis dann.
Bis dann.